สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูอาร์ตี้
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนโอเคกลับมาเจอกับเราสอง
คนอีกครั้งหนึ่งนะครับ
วันจันทร์สิครับสีเหลืองอยู่นี่ขอโทษครู
เอ๋ถามว่าที่ไหนเจอกันที่ไหน
วันไหน
มีผิดพลาดทางเทคนิคนิดหน่อยเราสองคนก็เลย
หัวเราะมากๆ
โอเคค่ะเจอกันวันอะไรนะคะวันจันทร์ครับ
วันจันทร์วันจันทร์นะคะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
เดือนนี้เดือนเมษายน
[เพลง]
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะข้อ 2
2023 แล้วตอนนี้ที่เราเจอกัน
เวลากี่โมง
นึกว่าครูเอ๋จะถามอย่างอื่น
ถามเวลาเวลา
2 ทุ่มครึ่งครับ 2 ทุ่มครึ่ง 2 ทุ่ม 30
นั่นเอง 2 ทุ่มครึ่งนะโอเคนะคะที่นี้วัน
นี้นะคะนักเรียน
ครูเอ๋นี่มีเรื่องจะมาเล่าให้ครูอันติกับ
นักเรียนเฝ้าเรื่องอะไรครับวันนี้
เรียกว่าเล่าไหมเล่าคือการพูด
1 ฟังแต่เป็นเรื่องที่ครูเอกอาจจะเล่า
นิดหน่อยแล้วก็ถามครูอาร์ตี้ว่าคิดยังไง
บ้างหรือว่าเคยเห็นไหมรู้จักไหมนะคะมาคุย
กันใช่ไหมมาคุยกัน
มาคุยเรามาคุยกันดีกว่าค่ะ
[เพลง]
ใช้กล้องเลยไหมคะ
เมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อนใช้กล้องกลัวตี้มี
กล้องถ่ายรูปที่แบบนี้ขับเลนด้วยหรอคะ
คนที่ไม่ใช่กล้องแล้วทำไมอ่ะเปิดที่ใช้
มือถือถ่ายรูปได้
มือถือถ่ายรูปง่ายกว่าง่ายกว่าเพราะว่า
กล้องหนัก
นะคะก็ตอนนี้ก็ใช้มือถือนะคะแล้วนักเรียน
ก็เอารูปนะให้ครูเอ๋ดู
คุณเอ๋ก็ชอบรูปนั้น
ก็เลยไปที่ที่นักเรียนถ่ายรูปแล้วครูเอ๋
ก็ถ่ายรูปให้เหมือนกับนักเรียนถ่ายรูป
นั้นน่ะรูปอะไรครับ
รูปเป็น
ครูเอ๋ขยับลูกไม่ได้ขอโทษค่ะ
เป็นยางลบอยู่
ใช่
เลื่อนไปอีก
จิ้มเลยครับ
ไม่ออกอ่ะ
ครับ
จิ้มไม่ได้ค่ะนักเรียนเดี๋ยวก่อนนะคะนัก
แปปนึงนะคะ
ความผิดพลาดทางเทคนิค
ต้องเปลี่ยนเมาส์ก่อนครับเปลี่ยนจาก
เรียกว่าอะไรครับเรียกว่า cursor ใช่ไหม
ภาษาไทยเรียกว่าตัวชี้
โอเคได้แล้วได้แล้วเย้โอเคมั้ย
มาหรือยังมาหรือยังมาแล้ว
[เพลง]
เมื่อกี้เห็นรูปชัดมั้ยคะ
เอารูปใหญ่ๆเลยนะคะ
ก็
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยก็ไปถ่ายรูปให้คล้ายๆที่นัก
เรียนถ่ายนะคะ
แต่ว่าถ่ายออกมาก็ไม่เหมือน
เพราะว่านักเรียนถ่ายรูปสวยมากนะคะ
ถ่ายรูปสวยมากครูเอกก็เลยลองถ่ายรูปในรูป
นี้เนี่ยนักเรียนจะเห็นเห็นอะไรคะครู
อาร์ตี้อันนี้เห็น
เราที่เรียกว่าจะให้ขวดที่เรียกว่าขัน
หรือเรียกว่าจอกดีครับขัน
ขันได้ขันเล็กๆอันเล็กๆนะโอเคได้ครับแล้ว
ก็มี
ก่อนจะพูดถึงอันนี้ครูอันที่เห็นตรงนี้
ไหม
ในข้างในนะคะ
เป็นน้ำเนาะอ๋อใช่มีน้ำอยู่ข้างในมีน้ำนะ
คะจริงๆแล้วข้างในอันนี้ค่ะ
นักเรียน
น้ำน้ำสะอาดสะอาดแบบนี้เลยน้ำใสๆนะคะน้ำ
แบบนี้น้ำใสๆ
แล้วก็มีตัวนี้ตัวนี้อะไรนะอ่ะสีฟ้าก็ได้
ค่ะ
เราก็จะเรียกว่าอ่างน้ำมนต์เนอะ
[เพลง]
ข้างในมีน้ำนะคะนักเรียนอะไรนะเมื่อกี้
ครูเอกพูดว่าน้ำอะไรนะ
อ่างน้ำมนต์น้ำมนต์โอเค
ทีนี้เนี่ยประเด็นก็คือ
ไม่ใช่ถ่ายรูปสวยแล้วนักเรียนให้ครูดูครู
สวยนักเรียนเอารูปมาให้ครูเอ๋ดูแล้วก็มี
คำถาม
อะไรน้ำอะไรนะคะน้ำอะไรนักเรียนบอกว่าครู
อันนี้น้ำอะไรเพราะว่าเขาเห็นที่วัดหลายๆ
วัดก็จะมีน้ำอันนี้อีกที่หนึ่งนะคะ
อันนี้เป็นรูปที่ที่นักเรียนเข้าไปถ่ายมา
นะคะเป็นรูปของอ่างน้ำมนต์ที่ที่ตรงพระ
พรหมเอราวัณ
[เพลง]
ที่คิดว่านักเรียนหลายๆคนก็น่าจะเคยไปตรง
ที่พระพรหมเอราวัณตรงนี้ใช่ก็
บริเวณตรงนี้นะคะนักเรียนเขาก็จะมีน้ำ
อ่างน้ำมนต์
ใช่ไหม
แล้วก็ยังมีอีกที่อื่นอีกนะ
ที่ไหน
เห็นไหมเห็นไหมเห็นไหม
เสาร์ของโบสถ์
แต่ไม่เห็นชื่อวัดอาจจะเป็นวัดพระแก้วไหม
ครับมีเสาสวยๆแบบนี้ครับเก่งมากใช่ค่ะที่
วัดพระแก้ว
ของเรานี่เองมันจะมีอ่างน้ำมนต์ด้วยขัน
น้ำมนต์ก็ได้นะใหญ่มาก
เราก็จะเห็นเอาดอกบัว
มีดอกบัวดอกบัว
เอาไปจุ่มในขันน้ำมนต์ให้น้ำติดดอกบัวมา
แล้วเขาก็เอามาทำแบบนี้เอามาทำอะไร
มาพรม
ที่ที่หัวหรือที่ศีรษะนะคะ
เอาดอกบัว
จุ่มไปในน้ำมนต์แล้วก็มาพรมจริงๆต้องพรม
ตัวเองนะ
พรมตัวเองหรือว่าพ่อแม่ลูกอ่ะเด็กๆคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่ก็เอาดอกบัวไปจุ่มในน้ำมนต์แล้วก็
พรม
เขาเชื่อว่าโชคดีอ๋อโชคดีโอเคไม่ใช่ไม่
ใช่พรมน้ำจะได้เย็นๆสดชื่นไม่ใช่ใช่ไหม
จริงๆก็เย็นนะ
อากาศร้อนๆมีน้ำเย็นๆ
คือประเทศไทยร้อนไงคะนักเรียนมีน้ำมนต์
แล้วก็รู้สึกร่มเย็นแล้ว
หน้านิดหน่อย
ความร้อนก็จะน้อยลงนะคะแต่ว่าอันนี้ไม่
ใช่น้ำสำหรับมาพรมแล้วไม่ให้ร้อน
โชคดีนะ
ปมแล้วรู้สึกว่าโชคดีขึ้น
ร่มเย็นก็คือใจเราเนี่ยจะได้ยิ้มอ๋อมี
ความสุขใจ
เย็นใช่นะคะนี่คือน้ำมนต์ที่วัดพระแก้วก็
มีนะ
เรียกว่าน้ำมนต์น้ำมนต์นะคะนักเรียนนัก
เรียน
[เพลง]
น้ำมนต์นักเรียนก็จะทำไมมีทำจากอะไรใช่
ไหมคะทำจากอะไรใช้สำหรับอะไรบ้างอันนี้ก็
เป็นคำถาม
งั้นเรามาดูที่น้ำมนต์ก่อนนะคะ
เคยเห็นเคยเห็น
มีขันน้ำมนต์โอเคลูกใหญ่พอไหมคะพอครับขัน
น้ำมนต์เอามาแล้วเราก็ใส่น้ำไปข้างใน
เพราะน้ำเอามาเฉยๆใส่ขวดไม่ได้เราต้องใส่
ขัน
เล็กก็ได้ใหญ่ก็ได้เนาะ
แล้วก็มีฝาปิดก็ได้หรือไม่มีฝาปิดก็ได้นะ
คะในรูปนี้ขันน้ำมนต์ที่มีฝาปิดแล้วก็มี
ขันเล็กๆข้างบนนะคะใช่
พอมีขันน้ำมนต์แล้วต้องมีอะไรอีก
ก็ต้องมีน้ำสิครับมีคันอย่างเดียวไม่ได้
ต้องมีน้ำใส่น้ำลงไปในขันด้วยแล้วต้อง
เป็นน้ำสะอาดนะคะนักเรียนเป็นน้ำสะอาด
น้ำขวดนี้ครูเอ๋ดื่มแล้วเอาไปใส่ไม่ได้นะ
คะ
ต้องเป็นน้ำสะอาดน้ำก๊อกก็ได้เนาะน้ำเปิด
มาก๊อกได้นะคะ
มีขันน้ำมนต์แล้วมีอะไรอีกคะ
[เพลง]
นะคะเป็นเทียนจริงๆเลยนะคะนักเรียนก็คือ
เทียนที่ทำจาก
ขี้ผึ้งหรอขี้ผึ้งหรือสีผึ้งใช่ไหมเหมือน
กับ
แล้วก็
แล้วก็ต้องมาปั้นมือด้วยนะปั้นมือ
เทียนปั้นมือส่วนมากก็จะสีขาวนะคะสี
เหลืองก็ได้สีขาวก็ได้นะคะจะใช้ 1 เล่ม
เทียนเราเรียกว่าเป็นเล่มนะใช้ 1 เล่มก็
ได้หรือบาง
เอ๊ะเห็นบางวัดก็ใช้อาจจะใช้มากกว่า 1
เล่มก็ได้
แต่ว่าธรรมดาก็ใช้ 1 เล่มพอแล้วนะคะส่วน
ใหญ่ก็ใช้ 1 เล่มครับนะคะก็อาจจะมีธูป
แล้วสิ่งที่จะเห็นอีกเวลาที่เขาใช้กับน้ำ
มนต์ก็คือจะเป็นอันนี้
เราเรียกว่าเป็นที่พรมน้ำมนต์ใช่ไหมใช่
ไม้พรมน้ำมนต์นะคะ
สะบัดน้ำมนต์ไปให้
น้องๆเมื่อกี้ในรูปน้องๆเอาดอกบัวไปจุ่ม
ในน้ำมนต์แล้วก็มาสะบัดใส่ใส่ที่หัวใช่
คือนักเรียนอาการเหมือนกันอย่างเช่นอะไร
นะเอาสะบัดมือใช่ไหม
แต่ว่าพอเป็นน้ำมนต์ก็จะเรียกว่าพรหมอ๋อ
จะได้รู้สึกว่า
สดชื่นร่มเย็นมีความสุขเพราะว่าเป็นน้ำ
มนต์
แต่ถ้าเราไม่มีอันนี้นะคะครูอาร์ตี้นัก
เรียนอยู่เมืองไทยไปวัดบางวัดบางทีเขาไม่
มีไม่มีไม้เขาเรียกไม้พรมน้ำมนต์เขาก็จะ
ใช้ใบของอันนี้ค่ะนี่เป็นรูปทับทิมแล้วก็
จะมีใบใบของทับทิม
ใบทับทิมก็เป็นกิ่งแบบนี้เลยนี่
เขาก็จะเอามา
ตัดมาทั้งกิ่งเลยเอามาพรมน้ำมนต์ได้
เหมือนกัน
ก็จะใช้ใช้ใบทับทิมได้
ใช้ใบทับทิมแต่ถ้าเป็นคนไทยคนไทยก็จะใช้
ใบนี้ค่ะครูอาร์ตี้
เห็นแล้วอยากกิน
อะไรมันคือ
มะยมครับ
ไม่ยอมมีรถเปรี้ยวครับ
เปรี้ยวมากแจ๋วมาก
ใช้ใบอาจจะ
3 ใบ 5 ใบ 7 ใบ 9 ใบ
ก้านมะยม
ก้านก้านก็จะเป็นแบบนี้มะยม 19 ก็จะมีใบ
อยู่หลายหลายใบ
เพราะฉะนั้นก็เวลาพรมน้ำมนต์ก็จะมีน้ำติด
ใบมะยมมาเยอะๆ
ตั้งแต่ 3 ใช่ไหมคะไปถึง 9 นะคะ
แล้วแต่นะคะ
[เพลง]
ไม้พรมน้ำมนต์ถ้าไม่มีไม้พรมน้ำมนต์นะคะ
แต่ในภาพที่ครูเอ๋ให้ดูเนี่ยเขาก็จะใช้
ดอกบัว
ดอกบัวจุ่มลงไปแล้วก็พรมตัวเองนะคะอันนี้
พรมตัวเองแต่ภาพที่นักเรียนถ่ายมาก็จะ
เป็นแบบนี้ก็เหมือนที่ครูเอถ่ายแบบนัก
เรียนก็คือมีขันธ์แล้วเราก็ตัดตัดแล้วเรา
ก็
เทลงมือแล้วก็พรมที่ศีรษะหรือที่ผมของเรา
เนี่ยที่หัวบางคนก็
แปะหน้าบางคนก็ตัวด้วย
ร่มเย็นร่มเย็น
กินได้ไหมครูเอ๋ถ้านักเรียนหิวนักเรียน
กินได้ไหม
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เขากินกันได้เหรอก็
สงสัยกินได้ไหม
เอาตามความเชื่อนะคะนักเรียนถ้าน้ำมนต์
ใหม่ๆ
สมัยที่ไม่มีโควิดสมัยที่เราเราไม่รู้จัก
ไวรัสแล้วก็น้ำสะอาดเนี่ยเขากินนะคะครู
อาร์ตี้เพราะว่าตอนเด็กๆอ่ะตอนเด็กๆควร
กินนะ
[เพลง]
แต่ถ้าตอนนี้เนี่ย
กลิ่นเราไม่รู้ไงครับเพราะว่าบางทีก็มีคน
หลายๆคนมาตักน้ำมนต์ใช้ขันใบเดียวกันอะไร
อย่างนี้เราก็อาจจะต้องระวังนิดนึง
แต่ถ้ามีคนที่กำลังอยากจะกินนะอันนี้นะ
อันนี้นะเขาก็เอาน้ำมนต์ใส่ใส่ขวดกลับ
บ้านแล้วก็เอาไปต้มโอเค
ไวรัสตายแล้วกินได้แต่ความโชคดียังอยู่
ความโชคดีไม่ตายนะความโชคดีไม่หายนะคะไม่
คือเอ๋เห็นนะคะเห็นคนทำแบบนั้นแต่ไม่รู้
ว่าเอ๊ะ
ยัง
โอเคไหม
โอเคไหมนะ
ครูเอกก็กินหรือดื่มนะน้ำมนต์นะกินดื่ม
โอเคนะคะอ่า
แต่ตอนนี้อืม
เพราะเราไม่รู้คนเดินมา
มีไวรัสหรือเปล่านะคะ
ต่อไปต่อไป
เดี๋ยวไม่จบจริงๆเมื่อกี้ถามเยอะทำได้ๆ
คือนักเรียนก็เอ๊ะสงสัยว่าแล้วๆน้ำมนต์
เนี่ยคือเวลาทำน่ะนักเรียนครูเอกว่าตรง
นี้ก่อนพระท่านนะคะจะมีพระนะพระ
แล้วก็
พระ
พระก็เอ่อ
พระท่านนั่งนะคะ
แต่ครูเอ๋วาดรูปพระยืนนะคะให้รู้ว่าคือ
พระก่อน
นั่งทำน้ำมนต์
คนธรรมดาทำไม่ได้ใช่ไหม
ปกติทำไม่ได้ใช่ไหมถ้ากลัวที่ทำไม่เรียก
ว่าน้ำมนต์นะต้องให้พระทำ
ครูแอนตี้ไม่ได้ต้องคนที่มีมนต์น่ะคนที่
เรียน
ไหมคะ
คือจะเป็นอ่าพระก็ได้พราหมณ์ได้หรือคนที่
เรียนนะคะคนที่เรียนนะคะเรียนน้ำมนต์
เรียนทำนะมนต์แล้วเขาก็จะมีมีเทียนเนาะ
เทียนทำน้ำมนต์เมื่อกี้ใช่ไหมสีขาวๆแล้ว
ก็มีไฟแล้วก็
ข้างล่างจะเป็นน้ำ
แล้วก็เทียนพอมีไฟปั๊บน้ำตาเทียนครูเอ๋
ให้เป็นสีอะไรสีเหลืองดีกว่าเนาะ
มีน้ำตาหยดลงไป
หยดลงไปหยดลงไปในน้ำพระท่านก็จะสวดมนต์
สวดมนต์ไปด้วยใช่ครับ
เราก็ไม่รู้ว่าท่านสวดมนต์อะไรบ้าง
ครูเอกไม่ทราบนะคะบทสวดสำหรับวันนี้แต่
ว่าเสร็จแล้วก็คือจะได้น้ำมนต์
น้ำมนต์มาเราก็จะบอกน้ำอันนี้เป็นน้ำ
สำหรับโชคดี
โชคดีอะไรอย่างเช่นสมมติว่าเด็กๆเนี่ยอัน
นี้เป็นหลานครูเอ๋เองนะคะหลานครูเอกก็พรม
น้ำมนต์โอ๊ยไอคิวดีๆนะ
เรียนเก่งๆ
[เพลง]
นะคะแล้วก็ใจเย็นๆนะห้ามใจร้อน
เด็กๆก็จะคิดแบบนี้นะคะ
หรือบางคนก็เชื่อว่า
มีน้ำมนต์แล้วก็มีรถ
มีรถไม่ได้รถเฉพาะคนใช่ไหมรถน้ำมนต์ให้
กับรถยนต์ด้วยได้เวลาที่ที่ซื้อรถใหม่
ก็อย่างที่บอกว่า
เอ๋เคยบอกไหมเรามีความเชื่อว่าที่รถนี่ก็
จะมีมีผู้หญิง
มีคลิปนะคะนักเรียนไปหาดูได้
มีผู้หญิงอยู่ในรถหรอซื้อรถมามีผู้หญิง
อยู่ในรถมาด้วย
เราเรียกว่าอะไรครับแม่ย่านางอ๋อแม่ย่า
นางคนไทยหลายๆคนเชื่อว่ามีแม่ย่านางอยู่
ในรถ
ก็จะต้อง
ผ่าน
อะไรนะเอารถเนี่ยไปหารถมาที่วัดแล้วพระก็
จะสวดมนต์แล้วก็พรมน้ำมนต์แล้วก็ให้แม่
ย่านางเนี่ยโชคดีแข็งแรง
เวลาที่เราขับรถไปแล้วเราเจอผีที่อื่นแม่
ย่านางก็จะสู้
ให้เราปลอดภัยใช่ไหมรถเรามีน้ำมนต์แล้วไง
มีน้ำมนต์ด้วยมีแม่ย่านางด้วยแม่ย่านาง
แข็งแรงด้วยก็ช่วยได้ใช่ไหมคะเราเชื่อว่า
นะคะแต่ต้องบอกนักเรียนนะคะอันนี้ศาสนา
พุทธไม่ได้สอนนะคะ
ศาสนาพุทธไม่ได้บอกนะคะ
ส่วนบุคคลด้วยใช่ไหมส่วนบุคคลนะคะส่วน
บุคคลบางคนก็รถเอารถไปรดน้ำมนต์บางคนก็
ไม่เป็นไรไม่เอาไม่ทำก็ได้ทำไหม
ปกติ
ซื้อรถมาก็ต้องเอารถไปใช่ไหมใช่เอาไป
ภรรยาบอกไปไม่ไปได้ไหม
ภรรยาไปคนเดียวปกติไม่ได้ไปปกติไม่ได้ไป
ภรรยาขับรถไปเลย
ก็เป็นความเชื่อนะคะนักเรียนเราเราก็ไม่
ว่ากันนะคะ
ก็ไม่เสียหายอะไรนะคะทำแล้วก็สบายใจก็ทำ
ความสุขก็ทำได้เลยครับ
แต่งงาน
แต่งงานก็มีรถน้ำมนต์เหมือนกัน
พอน้ำมนต์ที่เอามาใช้ในงานแต่งงานเขา
เรียกว่าน้ำสังข์
ทำไมเรียกว่าน้ำสั่งครับเพราะว่าพระจะทำ
น้ำมนต์เสร็จแล้วก็เอาน้ำอันนั้นน่ะใส่ใน
หอยสังข์ตรงนี้ชื่อว่าหอยสังข์ตรงนี้มี
น้ำมนต์ใส่เข้าไปในหอยสังข์เราก็เลยเรียก
ว่าน้ำสางน้ำสังข์ก็จะลดที่มือนะให้คนที่
แต่งงานเนี่ยโชคดีนะคะ
[เพลง]
ครูเอ๋วาดรูปน่าเกลียดมาก
นะคะก็เป็นน้ำสังข์แต่ว่าน้ำที่ใส่ก็คือ
น้ำมนต์
เห็นไหมมีอะไรอีกเดี๋ยวนะอาบน้ำมนต์ใช้
ได้หลายอย่างเลยนี่มีอันนี้สนุกมากครู
อาร์ตี้
ไม่ใช่คนไม่ใช่รถเท่านั้นช้างอ๋อ
มีรดน้ำมนต์ให้ฉันด้วย
[เพลง]
รดน้ำมนต์ให้ฉัน
มีเหมือนกันและที่สำคัญอยากจะถามครู
อาร์ตี้นะคะ
[เพลง]
เอาน้ำมนต์จากบาตร
คือไม่ใช่เป็นขันแล้วครูอาร์ตี้เห็นข้าง
หลังมันเป็นโอ่งเลยค่ะ
เคยได้ยินเคยได้ยิน
ไม่รู้แต่กลัวที่คิดว่าน่าจะไม่เคยทำไมกู
กูเอ๋จะไปอาบทำไมก็ในเมื่อพรมน้ำมนต์ก็พอ
แล้วไม่ใช่เหรอทำไมต้องอาบเลยอ่ะ
จริงๆนะครูเอ๋น่ะ
ครูเอ๋ไม่ชอบน้ำมนต์ของผู้ขอโทษนะ
มดอ๋อเป็นความเชื่อส่วนบุคคลถ้าใครชอบก็
ทำใครไม่ชอบก็ไม่เป็นไร
คือตอนเด็กๆอ่ะ
ที่บ้านครูเอ๋พ่อแม่ป้าเนี่ยชอบน้ำมนต์
มากแล้วเวลาที่ครูเอกไม่สบาย
ครูเอกไม่สบายบ่อยๆนักเรียนแต่ครูเอ๋ไม่
สบายเนี่ยไม่ใช่ไวรัสไม่ใช่แบคทีเรียแต่
ไม่สบายเพราะว่า
มันเป็นโรคที่คนไทยไม่รู้จักตอนนั้นโรค
ภูมิแพ้
ภูมิแพ้คือมีฝุ่นน่ะ
มันบวมครูเอ๋ก็หายใจไม่ได้
พ่อกับแม่กับคุณป้าพาครูเอ๋ไปหาหมอหมอก็
บอกไม่เป็นอะไร
หมอก็ยังไม่รู้ไม่รู้ว่าเป็นอะไรทำไมถึง
ไม่สบายทำไมถึงจาม
ประมาณ 50 กว่าปีที่แล้วหมอไม่รู้นะครู
อาร์ตี้นะครูเอกไม่ได้อยู่กรุงเทพฯไงอยู่
ต่างจังหวัดหมอก็ไม่รู้เป็นอะไร
แสดงว่ามีอะไรคะ
มีผีใช่ไหม
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เวลาไม่รู้อะไรก็พาลูกพากันไปไปที่วัด
ครับไปถามพระครับใช่ครูเอกก็เลยต้องอาบ
น้ำมนต์ตั้งแต่เด็กๆ
นะคะ
คือเราไม่สบายแล้วก็หนาวฉะนั้นเนี่ยถ้า
เราอาบน้ำมนต์แล้วเราสั่นแปลว่ามีผีจริงๆ
ครูเอ๋ก็ดูแล้วอ๋อถ้าสั่นเนี่ยพระจะเขาจะ
บอกว่ามีผีครูเอ๋ก็พยายามอดทนไม่ทันไม่
ทัน
โอเคไม่มีผีมันหนาวมันหนาวพอน้ำเนี่ยเย็น
ๆนะคะเย็นมากนะคะแต่ว่ามีคนที่เขาเชื่อ
ว่าอาบน้ำมนต์แล้วโชคดีเป็นความเชื่อส่วน
บุคคลคนเหล่านี้เขาก็จะไปที่วัดแล้วก็ไป
อาบน้ำมนต์กันครูเอ๋เคยอาบน้ำมนต์ทั้งหมด
ประมาณ 3 ครั้ง
ตอนเด็กๆนะคะ
แล้วก็ทำไมต้องอาบใช่ไหมคำถามคือทำไมต้อง
อาบแล้วครั้งสุดท้าย
เป็นยังไงครั้งสุดท้ายที่ครูเอ๋อาบน้ำ
มนต์
โกรธเพราะว่าเป็นแบบนี้
คือพระก็มีพระจริงกับพระไม่จริงอ่ะเนาะ
กดเพราะว่าต้องบอกนักเรียนว่า
เพราะมันมีแทงค์น้ำแบบนี้อยู่แบบนี้
ครูเอ๋รอคิวขึ้นไปอาบน้ำมนต์
แต่คุณป้าคุณป้าคือพี่สาวของคุณแม่บอกว่า
ไม่ได้เองไม่สบายบ่อยๆเอ๋ต้องอาบน้ำมนต์
มีคนบอกว่าที่นี่อาบน้ำมนต์แล้วดีเอ๋นะมี
ผีคุณป้าคิดเอ๋ก็นั่งอยู่ตรงนี้นั่งพิง
ตรงเนี้ย
มีเก้าอี้ตรงนี้
แล้วก็คุณป้า
แล้วก็พระอาทิตย์ร้อน
ตรงนี้เป็นแทงค์น้ำนะคะอ่า
แทงค์น้ำแล้วครูเอกก็เห็นมีรถ
เข้ามา
แล้วรถก็เอาน้ำแข็ง
นักเรียนรู้จักน้ำแข็งไหมเวลาเราจะกิน
โค้กเป๊ปซี่อะไรอ่ะอยากเย็นๆเราก็ใส่น้ำ
แข็งใช่ไหมใช่ครับใส่น้ำแข็ง
เขาก็เอาน้ำแข็งอ่ะเทลงไปข้างในอ่ะครู
อาร์ตี้
[เพลง]
ทำอะไรอ๋อมันร้อนก็เลยเทน้ำแข็งให้น้ำ
เย็นๆครูเอ๋ก็เข้าใจว่าอ๋อน้ำอันนี้
สำหรับคนดื่มคิดนะ
แต่ปรากฏว่าครูเอ๋เห็นผู้ชายวิ่งลงมาแล้ว
ตรงนี้มีก๊อกน้ำ
แล้วก็เปิดน้ำ
เปิดน้ำเย็นใส่
ใช่
แล้วก็เอาขึ้นไปข้างบน
สำหรับทำน้ำมนต์
แล้วครูเอ๋ก็ได้ยินเสียงคน
หนาวหนาวเราก็สั่นก็ได้ยินคนบอกมีผีมีผี
มีผีใช่ไหมเขาเชื่อว่ามีถ้าเราหนาวสั่นมี
ผีครูเอก็เลยอ๋อ
พอถึงคิวครูเอ๋เนี่ย
ครูเอ๋อดทน
หนาวมากอดทนอดทน
ไม่สั่นกูเห็นไม่สั่นนะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
แต่ครูเอกก็บอกป้าว่าพอไม่เอาแล้วครูเอ๋
ไม่ชอบอาบน้ำมนต์นะไม่ต้องพาไปครูเอ๋ต้อง
พยายามแข็งแรงนะคะแล้วก็อ่านหนังสือเอ๋
ไม่สบายอะไร
จนเจอคุณหมอบอกว่าอ๋อเอ๋แพ้ฝุ่นเวลามี PM
[เพลง]
2.5 เนี่ยครูเอ๋จะจาม
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ผีนะคะ
เป็นเรื่องของฝุ่นนะคะนั่นแหละ
ก็เลยเป็นคนไม่ชอบน้ำมนต์นะคะ
ไม่เคยแต่พรมน้ำมนต์เคยไหมแบบนี้
น้ำมนต์เคยถ้ามีพระพรหมน้ำมนต์ให้โอเคไหม
โอเค
ก็ได้นะคะนักเรียนถามว่าชอบไหมครูเอกไม่
ชอบ
โดยส่วนตัวไม่ชอบแต่ได้ไม่มีปัญหานะคะแต่
ถ้าหลบได้ครูเอ๋จะไกลๆ
พอเห็นอ๋อ
ทำไมกลัวน้ำมนต์
กลัวค่ะ
แต่ต้องบอกนักเรียนก่อนนะคะว่าเรื่องน้ำ
มนต์เนี่ยพระพุทธเจ้าไม่ได้สอนนะคะ
[เพลง]
ของบางคนเท่านั้นนะครับใช่
เมืองไทยแบบหนึ่งนะคะซึ่งบางวัดก็จะไม่มี
น้ำมนต์ไม่ทำน้ำมนต์บางวัดก็มีบางวัดก็
ไม่มีนะคะ
วันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จักเรื่องของน้ำมนต์
เป็นอีกอย่างนึงนะครับที่มาประเทศไทยแล้ว
ก็มีอาจจะมีโอกาสได้เจอน้ำมนต์นะครับ
ซึ่งนักเรียนจะชอบก็พรมนะคะชอบก็พรมแล้ว
แต่ความชอบของบุคคลครู acting ชอบไหมถาม
จริงๆ
ก็ได้ใช่ไหม
แค่กลัวที่ไปไหว้พระก็มีความสุขตรงที่ตรง
ที่เราไหว้พระแล้ว
ไม่ต้องมนต์ก็ได้ไหว้พระนะแต่ไม่ชอบน้ำ
มนต์
เป็นนิสัยส่วนตัวแต่ก็
เวลา
เราก็จะไม่พูดว่าเออไม่ชอบก็ไม่ดีก็โอเค
ได้ค่ะได้ค่ะ
เป็นผีหรอ
คะว่าน้ำมนต์คืออะไรใช้ยังไงนะคะนี่ก็ถ้า
ใครชอบก็ก็
ไปวัดให้พระท่านพรหมให้ถ้าใครไม่ชอบก็ไม่
ต้องพรมน้ำมนต์นะคะแต่ตอนนี้มีโควิดระบาด
ก็ต้องระวังนิดนึงนะคะก็ต้องระวังนะครับ
เราหมดเวลาใช่ไหมคะ
เดี๋ยวคราวหน้านะครับเราจะมีเรื่องอะไรมา
คุยกันเกี่ยวกับพระพุทธศาสนานะครับเดี๋ยว
ค่อยติดตามกันคราวหน้านะครับ
โอเคค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะ